aus
[Musik]
apa
mit sehr viel akzeptanz und toleranz
durch liebe gott und das imponiert mir
sehr
[Musik]
liebe fragt mich nach dem pass liebe
kann grenzenlos sein
liebe nimmt uns an der hand und schon
sind wir hin und weg
das sind schweizer liebesgeschichten aus
aller welt
[Musik]
ich bin's tiflis der hauptstadt
georgiens
da lebt bringt renz mit dem wachoffizier
sie sind eisfußball wo wir die grenzen
überwinden bevor sie wegen wach oder
anruf bringt krankhaft georgien aber
jetzt kann sie alles die spezialität
wohl nicht zuerst für herzog halten
die flüssigkeit von groupe saft mit der
finanzierung
es ist möglich sagt keller
ich probiere wechsel ganz harmlos exil
einloggen
ich wirklich gar nicht so sehr das ist
so
es ist stadtfest tiflis alle sind gut
lohnt obwohl fundortes tiflis im rössli
project und zwar buchstäblich trägt und
wachow einzig für das letztere
entschieden
wohnt im moment noch drei kilometer
auseinander
sogar will das für mich mit meinem job
wohl nicht einfach wirklich sehr
gespannt bin und ich mir gar nicht
wirklich an und und das muss immer alles
so organisiert werden dass ich überhaupt
nicht dankbar sie dass es überhaupt in
frage
zieht miteinanders für zara und dem elan
im museum begrenzt
[Musik]
die milan und von belgrad und darf pro
jahr nur drei monate der schweiz ändere
grinst das im moment noch nicht absehbar
zumal in eine größere wohnung
probier winkel auf russisch
in der kiste mit mami dann wurde wo sie
selber gemacht hat bevor sie gestorben
ist und ihre überreste mir am herzen
liegt hier muss einfach ganz sicher
monika die neue monitor ist für mich
ganz schwierig sie einer sitzt das
wissen sie ich nehme das hat sehr viel
ausgelöst im sinn von einem aber dann
muss ich das letzte und darum ist sarah
nach 18 jahren aus ihrer ehe uns
brauchen
heute gilt als sicher
neustadt die honig da ist für mich eine
flucht vor einfach alle nicht
zurückgreifen und hat aber jetzt ist
zeit für einen neustart
der plan ist dass er
vermutlich mit dedizierter irgendwann ja
untermain
das wichtigste er zahlte beim start in
das neue leben und große portion
zuversicht dass das mit ihrer und milan
burgund
[Musik]
bitteschön eben eine café am bahnhof an
die kunst für jeden tag und ich bedeute
sehr selten und ich hab mich aufstellt
kann
und da ich irgendwo hintergrund hat
sofort die grafik legt hat das nicht so
toll gefunden und da hat mir den sieg
geschenkt unternehmens gesprochen
[Musik]
kleine gelernt entwickelt unter wache im
selbsteinbau 2013 pro jahr ist sie dann
zu ihm und tiflis zucker der beziehung
wache hat sich aufs land und sind über
35 grad
geprägt von recker und andere kultur aus
brig und wenn man weiter solide
tatsächlich und wennigloh vieles
überdeckt aber es gibt ein paar dinge wo
man merke sind unterschiedlich
unterschied liegt das spaß zum beispiel
war ja das stimmt
rost macht auch spaß und ich merke dass
es mir spaß macht der muss man doch
irgendwie moritz winker erregen oder
sandra weiss ich es lustig aber du
machst manchmal gar keine miene
und dann will ich wissen das geht mir ab
diese kunst
[Gelächter]
berlin
[Musik]
mini erste große liebe
die 22 mann bzw
und ich glaube schon dass sie unbewusst
hat einfach
doris hofer ist nur noch selten in der
schweiz aber wenn immer möglich besucht
sie ihre familie ihre eltern wohnen
inzwischen sie werde mit 820 alter von
14 jahren
die storys activity of istanbul
ausgewandert ihre familie ist über den
entscheid nicht nur begeisterung sie den
untergang hofer sind stolz so viele
tochter und ihre enkel aber sorgen mache
dass ich ab und zu
besonders victory ski tennis sich
getrennt und es ist finanziell und
kinder werden oder sie und ihr partner
was sie liebt und seit 2 hertz ich bin
über den berg nähten so kommt die
validität kränkung der muslimischen
staat sich einander die gesellschaft das
gesetz nicht weit geräte klar ist ob
wohliger internationale startplatz aus
und jedes land als ganzes ist eine
andere gesellschaft
der vater hätte klar ihm einig die zeit
raum und zum thema scheidung wird noch
friedlicher im anime der ganzen familie
geschäft mit einer chronik wie sehr die
musik findet immer eine mieterin dass da
zieht der linie und im ausblick
ob schon heute praktisch er die zeit ist
das anders aber im stereo die homo-ehe
unter dem hintergrund hetzenecker bis im
leben sollte reichen berufs liter
schafft und das herz und sie hält es
stärke und sie hält das ziel und das war
dass sie das team wettbewerb sie ist
nicht auf dem weg sich auf ihrem werk
und dass sie das und mitgliederschaft
machen ich glaube es wird vierter und
wenn ich zurückblicke eine sterben aus
der verschlungene und gleichzeitig sind
wir wie aus einer hp führt und im moment
wenn du mich fragst mich glücklich
bibi mailbox
[Musik]
das ist für mich dass die fans trennen
die welt und ich glaube ich habe das
buch
[Musik]
georgi er liegt auf der grenze zwischen
europa und asien frühere sowjet-republik
sie knapp 30 land unabhängig kultur ist
faszinierend was liebe doris kreis zu
kurs lag
[Musik]
steve lees baut sich trends und wachovia
mit dem reiseunternehmen gemeinsam
existenz von fünf jahre als die beiden
einen blick die hellblauen auge schaut
hier sind wir ganz sicher lieber nach
dem ersten ja
kennengelernt hat sie sich in der
schweiz wurde war offenbar geschafft hat
das muss bis zum ende sein
einmal richtig ja
skisprung vorliebe szenige luft und
brigitte bach und steve lees bewohner
aber wenn man ihnen auf besucher spürt
mal der richtung vor ihrem gemeinsamen
leben das unglaublich zeitlich ist und
um die rapid- dass du hier bist so so
spürbar ich mit dem was ich dass ich
erwarte dass ich wirklich ist das ist
mir doch irgendwie schon aber bio dann
aber trat zwischen ihnen oder das ist
das ist ein ganzes dachte was für die
wachau ist die bz mit der brigittenau
erfahrung freundin gehört einfache zeit
also gegen interesse sind andere gewesen
sogar aus ich weiß nicht ich habe keine
große gedanken zusammen
im gegensatz zum wache hat brigitta
lange pck sich mitte mai aus westafrika
für taxi und ein dritter bleibt eine
neue form eigentlich kann jährige hat
weil alles neu und mein foto seien stolz
auf ihre geschichte wo man den widerruf
eurocup sicher bis wenn er frei ist
fällt das wahnsinnig befreiend um den
damen sind glaube ich bin ich viel
entspannter
die schweiz damit nicht mit mir nicht
zeigen dass hier konnten in der also ich
tue mir passen
wir sind 50 jahren kürte das heißt
scheint die ohne weiteres ein inder und
mich als interview wenn ich das welt hat
die welle
aber ich hatte es nie werden
[Musik]
martina vielen verschiedenen ort gewohnt
am längsten neu delhi bonnerin
diplomatische dienst und als journalist
coverte
es geht nur wenig schweiz sowohl bei ihm
der so viel wird wieder wärmer natürlich
auch dank seiner frau anna und ihre
familie bekannt ist
spezielle familien übrigens zu vermögen
sind gar disco wo der urgroßvater von
der razzia im auftrag von der engländer
opium auf hinaufsteigt austria zieht die
schau das anwesen als paar kilometer
außerhalb von mumbai spielt sich alles
so perfekt lässt die züge sind zurzeit
alles stimmen
wenn man verliert hat man das in fünf
minuten
und hier ist dass ich genau das
gegenteil
das wird mit der zeit schließlich noch
ein unterschied zu der schweiz sind die
husak stellte die familie vor der stasi
generationen hat
die parteilinie
[Musik]
es gibt viel zur musik sie senke die
letzte generation wohl am mittag stellte
lippi und das sehr gut so zieht das sich
in die vielerlei hinsicht endlich an
o'leary
das finde ich eine von der händler das
kastensystem sich bisher versuchen mit
trauer und mit ewald mit wem ich schaffe
das macht so viel problem weil der lerby
wenn man verliert ist man gar nicht und
wenn die eltern sind das nicht erlauben
wie bei meinen großeltern hat mir auch
nicht erlaubt aber wenn man stehe stark
nur gehe ich in der charakter der studie
[Musik]
raschere wohlhabende familie in
ammerland aufgewachsen bin bernard ist
es gerade umgekehrt
erika land in bescheidenen verhältnissen
geboren wurde
vielleicht hat genau das ihren respekt
gegenüber gestellt
regelmäßig laden zu sagen ja einfach und
zugleich wird aber lage sieht die g8
ihre stadt
[Musik]
ich habe mir jemand gewusst dass wenn
falls ich will dir eine freundin haben
dass wir deine ausländer aber irgendwie
so für mich in träume in das einem
belgien belgien gewesen
ich weiß nicht warum bin gern mal so was
für mich
[Musik]
der wache hat ist er 40 jahre lang
gelebt geologie studium bürgerkrieg viel
sport und mehrjährige abstecher nach
europa zum geschaffen
oestrich um die kids ein land also ja
das ist meine ich einfach ich sterbe
hier sicher weiß ich wie das georgische
wann mich bedeckt aber ich spüre mich
hier fremd ich weiß nicht das ist
einfach so
nachdem elf jahre in europa irgendwie
wartet erwartet man mindestens wer sein
nach hause kommt und ein progress sieht
reise also irgendwie sehe ich progress
aber ehrlich gesagt ich fühle mich fremd
weil wir sind also noch weit weg von
also
und man merkt der wache island darum
macht es georgien zwei mal mit pre gibt
sind die große liebe aus der schweiz die
tour ist steifer der schönsten seite
zeigen
kurt vergnügt mit
[Musik]
das ist schon eine reiseagentur die
wichtig stufe die region in der schweiz
und es kann eigentlich sehr darum bemüht
in kontakt und dies hier ist sehr studio
wo modulator führe also da die touren
vor allem für lüthi zum ersten mal nach
georgien wo sie eigentlich so viel wie
für uns schönste sache gesehen
[Musik]
hüt vierte wache und brigittes schweizer
touristen im kaukasus
[Musik]
reiseziel ich gern gates minder same war
über die kreis viersen auf über 2000
meter über meer
ja
ihre gäste barbara stöckl und der hans
fuhs luzern sind erstmals georgi und
begeistert von der landschaft jannati
heißt dieses gebiet stefan spindler und
das ist die regiert die dreifaltigkeit
die kirche ist auch bekannt dass in
schwierigen für bürger zeit hier können
also unsere schätze auch bereit ja ja
[Musik]
bei einem sari nach und das habe ich
sowieso erst drei jahren eigentlich nur
schöner macht finden und einfach wieder
fällt und so weiter und dass er
natürlich schon einfluss kann das lügen
wenn ich sage dass ich die relevanz oder
[Musik]
eines baumes vier tranchen unter bernard
goldhochzeit 50 über kulturelle grenzen
hinweg nette musik das ohne turbulenzen
mit respekt und neugier offenheit
[Musik]
in matera und treffe zu zwei frische
rote die berliner an der hand wer weiß
man das eben auf der hochzeit ihrer
cousine und die sind jetzt auf der
hochzeitsreise und müssen 50 jahre auf
der hochzeitsreise setzen
woher kommen sie ich bin eine party aus
mumbai dort vorn lässt mir ein schweizer
erinnern
und dieses schweizer fernsehteam filmte
und 50 jahre verheiratet
wir hatten unsere hochzeitsreise auch
hier im material
ich hoffe ihr schafft die 50 jahre auch
dann müsst ihr auch hier feiern
er hat mich gefragt ob frauen heute mehr
einfluss haben hast du meine zeit
was meint ihr bleibt stark wie eine
echte frau nicht schwarz wie manche
indische frau je mehr du zuerst desto
mehr wird für dich lieben das stimmt
seit keine muttersöhnchen steht zu euren
frauen
[Musik]
der in italien sonst aber wirklich nicht
also warum geht mir alles
ich versuche momentan kann ich nicht
machen wir nicht mit
[Musik]
gastfreundschaft wird georgien groß
geschrieben wird sie mit der familie vom
wache wo untergeschoss vom gleichen haus
wohnt
[Musik]
das war mein glück aber deine küche
[Gelächter]
das ist die kurzform ist das so dass
mein vater schotte dass sie bei filiale
kommen und wir mussten erfüllt will
general motors erste general mit ihrem
markt- und für ihre stadt funktioniert
festraum singen
ich bin so ehrlich mit dem wachen sinn
ihrer familie zusammen bedeutet familie
bis anders gelegt bei der blues ich
glaube es wird doch einfach wirklich nur
anders handhabt familie heißt du einen
anleger
sie haben als stadtplaner und ein jahr
gearbeitet
er hat den freiheitsplatz mitten in
tiflis gebaut
wie hat sich das leben verändert in
tiflis in den letzten 20 jahren was
jetzt auch seit seite georgien
unabhängig ist
für alle aber egal was du ansprichst
früher haben viel geschafft
also hat der ex oriente wo sich
rinkeroder ist also du kannst sie beide
haben also 130 franken zusammen es hat
auch harte sehr viel gearbeitet so leben
meist noch schwimme ich finde nicht dass
wir schon im land viele menschen haben
überhaupt gangs habt ihr schon darüber
geredet weißt du wollt ihr in tiflis
auswerten oder überlegt ihr euch dann
irgendwann in die schweiz so weit haben
wir nur noch nicht geschaut dass wir
wollen zusammen out werde es werden wir
mal
zuerst waren alt da schauen wir dann
mache ich mir gar keine sorgen
man hat sich einfach wenn man also bald
wird es nicht inc das sei so gewesen sei
wir versuchen das zu verschleppen
eric anwälte werk entstehen kann
[Gelächter]
herzlichkeit und georgi bei die uhr
geht's fremde uns andere aus bäriger
kreis leicht rezept
meine tochter ist ihre idee osmin zurück
und ich habe zwei kinder
und das bindet
ich glaube nicht dass die haare caro
nicht in die tochter und ich möchte die
ohne
ich bin so froh wie alles gekommen ist
alles passt perfekt meine situation im
job mit der familie mit doris wirklich
perfekt ich bin sehr dankbar
der bbi ist vor nur zwei jahren im
sommer 2016 slammer in der türkei massiv
erschüttert wurde
teil vom türkischen militär und probiert
die türkische regierung und um erdogans
stürze der putschversuch ist
niedergeschlagen wurde
erst noch woche hat sich situation für
bevölkerung einigermaßen normalisiert
auf ihrer familie vor der doris hofer
ist ein schwieriger moment sie seine
stöß selber 12
vor wiederum weg der sommerferien sind
noch gut unterwegs
los angeles sie mit der ring und london
und durch hecken wird telefon und eu
frage kommt wenn wir sie mit turkish
airlines flogen und der militärstadt und
da gehst du schon mal nach
also wirklich vor situationen oder
biblis große tanne aus welches überhaupt
rücktritt auch irgendwie beruhigt also
ob denn nehmen und durch show vertreten
was wenn nur und mit großem glück dass
in der schweiz also möglichkeiten
[Musik]
jetzt zwei jahre später ihr gesicht lag
sie ist am pool entspannt seit doris
zivile die türkei blieben zimmer mit dem
creme und ihrer patchwork familie sucht
das neueste high
[Musik]
will jetzt wenn es morgen alle
miteinander und so richtig zum leben
über alle grenzen und hindernisse hinweg
das ist wirklich heimat und und da
wollen wir und das ist gut ich bin
wieder hier ganz der holzernte nebraska
sie und wo hier born and raised und dem
sender gleichzeitig als schweizer fan
von mir schweizer identität roma-politik
es ist ein zitat wonach im jahr 2008
news
[Musik]
warum hätte thomas dummermuth ist mental
alles hinter sich noch und die sprache
und wie einfach ist in das gefühl dass
wir sie finden den weg für die
hauptstadt linken und die suche als
erstes die presbyterianer 4
thomas schaaf thomas ist ein loch fahrer
aber es ist eher weltlichen ihr weg sie
wohin linken geführt hat die sonde junge
amerikanische ärztin
heiko thomas dummermuth tatsächlich und
ich habe denke du in burg aus dem 1
und das ist alles was ich hier so wie
die schweiz wird sehr genau aber der
teppich der amerikanische grenze aber
das ist ja eigentlich gegner oder die
reformierte geist ist doch eine foto
mobilisiert die version vom
protestantischen glauben und dem platz
da vorne wo der kanzler
ach ja genau wir sind wieder vorkommen
kann nur sagen ich finde ich weiß du
stehst da als schweizer pfarrer immer
noch die amerikanische flagge
da das an ich glaube ich also
innerschweizer fehlen und jetzt dass man
irgendwie zu fahren
wieso wird das ist direkt einfluss auf
den blauen ja also wenig machen und
gleichzeitig ist tradition ist tradition
in die usa der letzte sagte mein leben
aber ja ich will mich hier für
gottesdienste und nicht ohne stolz den
schmerz darüber um unabhängigkeitstages
patriotischen und und muss man auch auf
zunge ist dass sie nicht aussagen
abweichen
ob frage etwa durch und empfangen aus
maintal und fahrer aus der schweiz
plötzlich der anruf nebraska etwas denkt
20 theologie studiert hat uns amerika
und ich wäre in jedem jahr aber
grundsätzlich bin ich auch flexibel was
geht ab er hat mini unbedingt
vorgestellt durch die usa trauer ist da
setzt gottes ruf gefolgt ist oder ein
anruf oder johnny depp ist das ist okay
das ist jetzt es geht
das geht jedoch nur die antwort ja was
muss ein mensch was muss eine frau h das
alles trug dort das muss man schauen ja
ich hoffe das kann man nicht so einfach
von den punkt bringen und sind dann weiß
ich es ist einfach gut
nächste woche lernen sie die frau jenny
verkennen und auch die amerikanische
version von all den corner mittels und
liter wasser trinken
mit der baum mit dem sohn vor gott kuala
lumpur bereitet sich jeanette und peter
auf ihren schönsten tag und sind ihr
seid rasch nach dem haus liegen die noch
ich fühle mich so beglückt dass ich hin
und weg
[Musik]